donner une valeur et une opinion sur
l'authenticité d'un bijou d'un tableau
bien d'un objet d'art
voici le principe de cette journée d'
expertise gratuite
exceptionnellement qu'à miser ce jeudi
17 janvier à versailles
nous sommes une maison de vente aux
enchères donc on
organise des journées des expertises et
des ventes aux enchères à la fois à lyon
dans notre hôtel des ventes et à paris
les expertises se font dans nos bureaux
dans le 6e et les vente à l'hôtel drouot
cette baignoire entre 100 et 200 euros
j'avais quelques objets de
dont j'ignorais la valeur je voulais
préciser les choses dans ses peurs pour
leur régler des successions pour l'est
les partages amazon mes enfants
succession inventaire pour assurance ou
gestion d'une collection d'art les
raisons sont multiples pour venir faire
estimer son objet gilone a apporté des
bijoux appartenant à ses ancêtres des
broches un portable selon elle et qui
l'encombré j'ai une estimation pour
chaque chaque pièce et on verra on verra
si c'est sa part le som fouet dans les
500 euros chaque objet oui à peu près
oui je ne serais même pas tant vous
voyez pas ce que cherche des bijoutiers
on n'en proposait rien du tout les
bijoux de givonne seront vendues aux
enchères le 20 février prochain à paris